good morning Hank it's Tuesday so last
week I made a video about the company
cepheid and their parent company
danaher's amazing but expensive
tuberculosis tests and like minutes ago
as I'm recording this usaid the global
fund and the stop TB partnership issued
a joint statement saying that danaher's
standard TB cartridge would reduce in
price from ten dollars to
7.97 which isn't the 50 reduction we
hoped for but is extremely extremely
significant and it's significant in part
because danaher has committed to making
no profit in poor countries from their
standard TB cartridge also I've heard
that danaher is committed to allowing a
third party to come in and verify their
at Cost pricing and to do so on a
regular basis so that if the cost of
manufacturing goes down the cost of the
test will too also danaher just agreed
to improved maintenance conditions
making it easier to fix the gene expert
tests when they break all the of this is
um
amazing news just to State the obvious
this is really important progress for
those living with and fighting TB and
it's a big win for our community as well
as the folks we've worked in deep
partnership with many of whom have been
involved in this fight for years Doctors
Without Borders the treatment Action
Group and Partners in Health among
others here's why it's a big deal let's
say cepheid sells 10 million of these
cartridges per year at the reduced price
over a decade that will save the world's
most impoverished communities 200
million dollars but I know it's easy to
think about this stuff in terms of
numbers or dollars but I also want to
think about it in terms of people's
individual experiences like last week on
vlogbrothers WE hosted a live stream
that included one of my heroes the TB
Survivor and activist fumeza tessile
whose TB took over a month to diagnose
because they saw the situation I was in
I mean I was like my lowest weight 32 kg
and that's what it is in pounds in
American Canada that's 70. it's very
thin so they said I must do a Chex X-ray
and then I go to another clinic to get a
checks X-ray and then I was diagnosed
through the checks X-ray and because she
was only diagnosed by a chest x-ray her
doctors didn't know that she had drug
resistant TB and so she was put on the
wrong drug regimen at first and
eventually she was in continuous
treatment for over three and a half
years during which she had to take over
000 pills and if fumesa had been
diagnosed immediately and accurately
with a gene expert test she could have
been spared so much suffering she might
not have lost her hearing or had to go
through years of disabling illness
that's the kind of change in individual
lives less expensive Gene expert tests
can bring and so when we talk about
Millions more tests being available
we're really talking about the
opportunity to help transform millions
of lives for the better now despite all
this I do still have some mixed feelings
like I take danaher at their word that
7.97 sense is their cost but I look at
the cost of the xdr the extensively drug
resistant tuberculosis test and I just
wish that had also reduced in price and
I do hope that eventually cepheid and
danaher may take a similar approach with
their xdr cartridges as they have with
their standard ones because I just think
it would be such good news for patients
and also for the world because it would
help us to prevent the most dangerous
strains of TB also I've heard that some
folks involved in this including
potentially people in our community have
resorted to name calling and even
threats toward people who work at these
companies and I want to be very clear
that is unacceptable it is a total
violation of our community's guidelines
for activism and also it makes
everything worse so please and I realize
I'm talking to a tiny minority of people
here but please don't do that ever I've
experienced those threats and all they
make me feel is resentment and fear and
anger which makes Mutual understanding
and compromise vastly more difficult so
yeah there are definitely some
complicated feelings here and I do think
we should continue to advocate for lower
cost Diagnostics especially for those
xdrtb cartridges but we need to do that
in a way that is polite and respectful
and also reflects the reality that these
companies have made choices that expand
access to diagnostics for the people who
need the most so yeah the work is
definitely not finished really it's just
beginning this week I'm going to be in
New York to continue conversations about
tuberculosis at the United Nations which
is a weird thing to say also on Friday
I'm going to be part of an author event
at NYU with some of my heroes and it's
free you should come Link in the
doobly-doo Hank the last thing I want to
say is this early in 2007 way back when
we were just beginning Brotherhood 2.0 I
was hospitalized for an infection
between my eye and my brain and Hank us
people in our community to take pictures
of them with stuff on their heads to
cheer me up and of the 400 or so people
who regularly watch those videos about
350 people sent in pictures and this was
before it was easy to send digital
pictures this was before the iPhone and
when I was in this hospital bed watching
that video seeing all these people with
ridiculous stuff on their heads it was
the first time when I thought my God
this community has a lot of energy in it
they want to do interesting stuff
together I just remember thinking this
feels like it could be really special
and so it has proven to be I mean the
idea that 16 and a half years later the
organizational and creative talents of
nerdfighteria would be harnessed
together not to cheer up one guy in a
hospital but to expand TB treatment and
Diagnostics to millions that is awesome
I am genuinely in awe of you and you are
truly May made of awesome Hank I just
want to leave you with three words that
I've had to learn over and over again
these last 17 years never underestimate
nerdfighteria
I'll see you on Friday